I thought we'd make you know help the  audience make a sailor connection by  showing some of their craigslist ads  right here on the show first up man  seeking woman like being wined and dined  then come drink four loko with me behind  Taco Bell over 100 not so gently worn  Panama by my new book how to look /  menen  wanted your fingerprints on my shovel no  questions  roommate wanted must be clean courteous  and not allergic to albino rats also  must pay rent on time really love albino  rats willing to share chores and ok with  the shrieking lovemaking sounds about  bye no rats PS I have albino rats for  sale a large trunk full of my old sex  toys  many of them are steam-powered  [Applause]  for hire  I'm the Indonesian Tim Gunn  [Music]  woman seeks confident dependable man for  long-term relationship  just kidding woman seeks drunken hookup  with roided-up man a and finally meet a  hug then you're a huge wussy and I'll  beat the crap out of you  [Applause]  we learn the line